si la fréquentation des trains connaît
une chute vertigineuse à cause du coc
u19 les entreprises qui les fabriquent
elles se portent bien
les carnets de commandes sont pleins
pour plusieurs années c'est le cas par
exemple de faiveley à saint pierre des
corps et la ville aux dames et
l'équipementier compte parmi ses clients
des géants comme alstom la sncf ou
encore la ratp et il espère bien croquer
prochainement dans un très gros gâteau
le renouvellement est des 146 rame du
rer b et lucas chopin vous ne connaissez
peut-être pas son nom mais vous avez
déjà passé ses portes à saint pierre des
corps fèves les transports produit de
nombreuses pièces de train ce site de
fabrication de portes est unique en
france
faiveley détient plusieurs centres de
compétence mondiaux de multiples savoir
faire qui leur permettent d'obtenir tous
types de marchés comme celui ci la
rénovation du tramway de tours et 2c
pantographe le pantographe c'est
l'origine même de faiveley transport
puisque louis faiveley est l'inventeur
du pantographe il a déposé un brevet en
1911 et il a créé la société autour du
pantographe en 1919
portes palières de métro parisien
morceaux de trains français et étrangers
la liste des chantiers est longue pour
ce sous-traitant d'alstom aujourd'hui
faible et espère décrocher le contrat du
rer b du pain béni pour ses 450 salariés
on a eu les trains régiolis régio2n on a
le tgv 20 20 le projet est mis 20 ou rer
b c'est le dernier gros projets il est
important qu'on soit dessus parce que ça
va nous permettre de pérenniser l'emploi
aussi bien pour la partie ingénierie
pour la partie production donc les
enjeux sont énormes sur ce dernier
projet faible et a fêté ses 100 ans en
2019 espère faire vivre encore longtemps
ces savoir faire à la française